JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome to recitation.
In lecture, you started
learning about vectors.
Now vectors are going
to be really important
throughout the whole
of this course.
And I wanted to
give you one problem
just to work with them in a
slightly different context
than what we're going
to do in the future.
So this is the context
of Euclidean geometry.
So some of you have
probably seen this problem
that we're going to
solve, but you probably
haven't seen it
solved with vectors.
So let's take a look at it.
So what I'd like
you to do is show
that the three medians of a
triangle intersect at a point,
and the point is 2/3 of
the way from each vertex.
So let me just remind
you of some terminology.
So in a triangle, a
median is the segment
that connects one vertex to the
midpoint of the opposite side.
So here, this point M is
exactly halfway between B and C.
So OK.
So every triangle
has three medians--
one from each vertex
connected to the midpoint
of the opposite side-- and
what I'm asking you to show
is that these three medians all
intersect in the same point.
And also, that this
point divides the median
into two pieces, and
the big piece is twice
as large as the small piece.
So this is 2/3 of the median,
and this is 1/3 of the median.
So, why don't you take a few
minutes, work that out-- try
and do it using vectors as much
as possible-- pause the video,
come back, and we can
work on it together.
So hopefully you had some
luck working on this problem.
Let's get started on it.
So to start, I actually
want to rephrase
the question a little bit.
And I'll rephrase it to
an equivalent question
that's a little bit
more clear about how
we want to get started.
So another way to
say this problem is
that it's asking us to
show-- so for each median,
say this median AM here, where
M is the midpoint of side BC,
there exists a point on
the median that divides it
into a 2:1 ratio, so the point
that's 2/3 from the vertex
to the midpoint of
the opposite side.
So for example, you know,
there's a point-- so,
let's call it P, say, at
first-- so there's a point P
such that AP is twice PM.
OK?
And similarly, there's
some point-- maybe called
Q-- that's 2/3 of the way from
B to the midpoint of this side.
And there's some point
that's 2/3 of the way from C
to the midpoint of this side.
And so an equivalent
formulation of the question
is to show that these
three points are really
the same point.
That they're all
in the same place.
So one way we can
do that is that we
can compare the position
vectors of those three points.
And if those three points all
have the same position vector,
then they're all in
exactly the same position.
So in order to do that
we need some origin.
And it happens that
for this problem,
it doesn't matter
where the origin is,
and so I'm not going
to draw an origin,
but I'm going to call it O.
So we're going to set up
a vector coordinate system
with origin O. And
now I want to look
at what the vector from O to
P is in terms of the vectors
connecting O to A,
B, and C. Right?
Those are the vectors
that determine
the vertices of the triangle.
And so I want to relate
the location of P
to the locations of A, B, and C.
So the first thing to do
is that-- well, in order
to talk about where P is, I
know how P is related to A and M
and I know how M is
related to B and C.
So let's first figure out
what the position vector of M
is in terms of the position
vectors of A, B, and C,
and then we can use
that to figure out
the position vector of P.
So M is the midpoint
of the segment BC.
So I think we saw
this in lecture.
What this means is that the
position vector OM is exactly
the average of the position
vectors of B and C.
It's 1/2 of the
quantity OB plus OC.
All right?
So it's easy to
express the position
vector of the midpoint
of a segment in terms
of the position vectors
of the endpoints.
You just add the position
vectors of the endpoints
and divide by 2.
So if you like,
this is equivalent
to the geometric fact that the
diagonals of a parallelogram
bisect each other.
So that's the
position vector of M.
Now we have to figure out what
the position vector of P is.
So in order to do
this we can note,
that in order to get from
the origin to point P,
well, what we have to do is we
have to go from the origin--
wherever it is--
to A, and then we
have to go from A 2/3 of
the way to M. All right?
So the vector OP is equal to
OA plus 2/3 of the vector AM.
Right?
Because we go 2/3
of the way from A
to M in order to
get from A to P.
This is because we've chosen
P to be the point that
divides segment AM into a 2:1
ratio so that AP is 2/3 of AM.
OK.
So good.
So now we need the vector AM.
Well, we know what the
position vector of A is.
It's just OA.
And we also know what the
position vector of M is.
It's OM.
So that means that AM is just
the difference of those two
vectors.
It's going to be OM minus OA.
Another way to say this is that
if you add OA to both sides,
you have that OA
plus AM equals OM.
In other words,
to go from O to M,
first you can go from O to
A, and then go from A to M.
All right.
And I've just subtracted OA
onto the other side here.
So we can write AM in
terms of OM and OA.
And we also-- we have
an expression for OM
here in terms of OB and OC.
So that means we can
get an expression for AM
in terms of OA, OB, and OC.
So let's do that.
So that's just by substituting
from here into here.
So if I do that,
I get that AM is
equal to-- so OM is
1/2 OB plus 1/2 OC,
and now I just subtract OA.
All right.
So that's what AM is, putting
these two equations together.
I get that that's AM.
And so now I need to
figure out what OP is.
So for OP, I just
need to substitute
in this new expression
that I've got for AM.
So I have OP is
equal to, well it's
equal to OA plus 2/3
of what I've written
just right above-- 2/3 of AM.
So that's 1/2 OB
plus 1/2 OC minus OA.
OK.
And so now you can multiply
this 2/3 in-- you know,
just distribute the
scalar multiplication
across the addition there--
and then we can rearrange.
We'll have two terms involving
OA and we can combine them.
So we'll see we have a
plus OA minus 2/3 OA.
So that's going to
be equal to 1/3 OA.
And then we have, OK
so 2/3 times 1/2 OB.
So that's plus 1/3
OB plus 1/3 OC.
So this gives us
a simple formula
for the position vector of
P-- that vector OP-- in terms
of the position
vectors of A, B, and C.
So in particular,
it's actually--
because P is the special
point-- it's 1/3 of their sum.
Of the sum OA plus OB plus OC.
OK, so that's where P is.
Now to finish the
problem, I just
have to show that this is the
same location as the point that
trisects the other medians.
So how would I do that?
Well, I could go
back to my triangle
and I could do exactly
the same thing.
So I could-- maybe I'll give
this point a name, also.
I'll call this midpoint N, say.
So I could let Q be the point
that lies 2/3 of the way
from B to N. And then
I could write down
the position vector of N
in terms of OA, OB, and OC.
And then I can use that to write
down the position vector of Q
in terms of OA, OB, and OC,
and I'll get some expression.
And what will
happen at the end--
I hope if I'm lucky--
that expression
will be equal to this expression
that I found over here.
OK?
So you can go
through and do that,
and if you do that, what you'll
find is that in fact it works.
So there's actually a sort
of clever, shorter way
of seeing that.
Which is that this formula
is symmetric in A, B, and C.
So that means if I just
relabel the points A, B, and C,
this expression for the
position vector doesn't change.
So rather than going
through that process
that I just described,
you can also
say, well, in order
to look at, say Q,
instead of P, what I
need to do is I just
need to switch B and A. I need
to do exactly the same thing
but the roles of A and
B are interchanged.
Well, if the roles of A and
B are interchanged, then
in the resulting
formula, I just have
to interchange the
roles of A and B,
but that won't change the
value of this expression.
So by symmetry, the point I get
really is going to be the same.
If you don't like
that argument, I
invite you to go
through this computation
again in the case of
the other medians.
In either case, what you'll find
is that the points that trisect
the three medians all
have position vector 1/3
OA plus 1/3 OB plus
1/3 OC, but that means
they're the same point.
So what we've shown then,
is that the points that
trisect the three medians--
that trisects, that divide them
into 2:1 ratios from the
vertex to the midpoint
of the opposite side-- that
those three points all have
the same position vector.
So in fact, they're
the same point,
and that's what we
wanted to show, right?
We wanted to show that there's
one point that trisects
all three of those medians.
So we've shown that the three
points that trisect them
are actually the same.
So that's the same conclusion,
phrased differently.
So I think I'll end there.